e aí mulher como é que tu tá agathon e
aí é comemorado com vocês pois a galera
quer começar uma parada série com você
hoje
hoje está tudo tão diferente né pessoas
pessoa tão diferente ato tão diferente
ato tão tão distante antigamente
antigamente a gente acordava tinha uma
mensagem daquele amithab sms aquele que
reconquistou de mensagens de deus
ilumina as pessoas vocês são os amigos
com os anjos
os anjos são os amigos das pessoas que a
minha vida é porque você meus amigos
você não aguentava a mensagem toda a
baixada baixar o bacharel baixar a
baixar baixava achar lá embaixo a cimpor
tarde a mim ali aquele tempo a pessoa a
pessoa te mandar a mensagem que está a
50 centavos da amizade é isto é amizade
você gastar 50 etapa falar com amigos e
hoje em dia com a de saber se a cópia ro
tamanho de seu antebraço e mais gratos a
todos os amigos de hoje é isso o que o
amigo e oferece hoje em dia o olympique
tem gente vamos ser mais amiga
tecnologia veio para ajudar a gente mas
parece tratar distância antigamente
chegar na casa dos amigos entrar você
pedir a água hoje em dia você chega na
casa da minha primeira vez e pegar
sendai fainé a água você lembra de bebê
mas hoje em dia a casa do amigo e não
tenho aí foi a mesma pessoa deixa de ir
porque não tem faixa volver lembro aqui
às vezes você vai na casa da amiga você
entra na casa às vezes vai faz já
conectar automaticamente começa a casa
do amigo meu que me foi conectada
automaticamente já me sinto parte da
família aí gente essas coisas distância
de mais antigamente você estava um chat
e pedir seu amigo para conversar com
você hoje em dia centro shopping light
com a gente vamos ser amigos vocês vocês
que são loucos fazem ali só assim e aí
mulher como é que tá tudo bem mulher
isto como é que tu tá tudo bem também
mulher a mulher com ele depois de tanto
conversar comigo não fez chover você
está conversando ali car ainda estava
começando fez depois não fez não vai na
casa da pessoa com vai se passeiam se
chega nessa fase é ruim ou como é bonito
chegar porque só assim eu fui muito bom
ninguém mais fala hoje ninguém dá bom
dia ninguém fala tudo bem com você quer
saber de lá que lá estive lá que você
também quer saber dele que você perde lá
ele mas é diferente desse que é como se
fosse uma troca de favores e eu eu dou
um pouco de alegria pra vocês e vocês
retribui
kanu gostei é diferente por causa de
cook county meu corpo e minha foto e
curti minha posição porque mel com co
antigamente chegava o filme começasse
mulher ficou sabendo de que mulher
paulinha ficou com o carro não percebeu
mulher conturbado mulher checotah chega
aqui e aí a pessoa que conversava era
fugir mas conversava onde se faça e não
é que ficou sabendo de que mulher aline
ficou paulo é que história é essa bem
que vou te mandar os pedirei que matt
szabo raposa conversa
assenta por voto celular longe se ela
caísse lá no rio carregando estava
carregando lá deixei lá quebra uma hora
vai conversar com pessoas estão pedindo
pra vocês pra vocês serem mais humanos -
máquinas até que você comente aqui no
youtube ou no facebook você vai no
facebook do que você sente mais falta eu
sinto falta disso esse fato de as
pessoas conversarem com ela sabe assim
interagir com elas você não tivesse você
clica e não gostei vai estar ajudando
muito cada vez que você clica no botão
você está espalhando um pouquinho a
palavra mais pessoas se você tiver no
facebook clique em compartilhar marca
alguns amigos em que você acha que está
viciado demais o que não conversa mais
com as pessoas mantêm os amigos então
isso aí valeu é nóis
eita foto da p